i was born too late to explore new lands
and a bit too early to explore the stars
above but i was born just in time to
explore those crazy deltarune theories
and memes but let me tell you these
deltarune theories can get pretty crazy
i mean i thought other game theories
like zelda theories can get wild but the
zelda franchise doesn't have things like
determination or wd gaster going for it
oh wait that's undertale not deltarune
and they're not connected right so
they're totally connected don't believe
what other people say if you've played
deltarune's brand new chapter 2 then no
worries you can safely watch everything
in this video without concern for
spoilers but if you haven't played
chapter 2 or chapter 1 for that regard
and are concerned about spoiling the
story then consider this your one and
only spoiler warning for the entire
video now with that out of the way i
want to bring attention to one very
particular very peculiar detail that's
brand new in delta in chapter 2
specifically i'm assuming that most of
you watching this are familiar with
undertale and the characters from that
game that are making an appearance in
the world of deltarune in fact pretty
much everyone has resurfaced in the new
game at this point except for one
extremely major character asriel
well kind of see he's spoken about
positively by seemingly everyone in the
light world since he seems like he was
quite the go-getter and friendly kid
about town when he lived at home but
that's just it asriel's memory and
influence was restricted to the past in
the light world where he lived obviously
the majority of the game so far takes
place in the rpg-esque dark world where
only items and people brought into the
fountains from the light world exist
this was proven somewhat in chapter 1
but explicitly proven in chapter 2 off
the bat when chris and susie enter the
school dark world but find it empty
except for rawlsy rosie asks chris to go
back to the light world and grab a bunch
of cards and board games and when chris
returns bada bing bada boom the dark
world all of a sudden is filled with
things and people going off of this fact
alone you might be tempted to think that
the dark world isn't a real world at all
but rather just good old youthful
imagination from some school classmates
using items and toys around them i mean
chris is a huge fan of d and susie and
noel continually refer to the dark world
as a dream in their ferris wheel ride
but due to several other factors we know
that while the dark world might feel
like a fake world influenced in a big
way by its location and contents in the
light world it is in fact a real world
that multiple people can go to and
experience and remember after the fact
and in some cases carry their
experiences with them to the light world
if you continue down the alternate route
aka the weird route aka the snow grave
route you get proof of this because noel
uses snow grave a lethal ice attack that
the route is named after on the party's
fellow classmate birdly and it kills him
or at least completely incapacitates him
even after returning to the light world
everybody else comes back but birdly
just doesn't wake up after the fountain
is destroyed and after this it's assumed
that the party then stuffs him into the
nearby closet yeah pretty dark stuff but
this is all typical of toby fox games in
addition to experiential proof that the
dark world exists there is also the
existence of the single strangest
character in deltarune besides the clown
and the glitchy salesman of course
rosie's entire existence is so bizarre
because even when the dark world is
emptied of inhabitants and all its
fountains are closed rawlsey strangely
still lives on we know this because in
chapter two after chris and susie closed
chapter one's dark fountain rosie
apparently worked non-stop on making
chris and susie some rooms in his castle
while the duo were in the light world he
was able to make multiple complete rooms
in a single day but attributes it to the
fact that apparently he never stopped
working since they left and even
stranger is that rousey can exist in
other worlds created by other dark
fountains even though no other darkeners
can do that rawlsy is the one who
explained that darkness can't exist away
from their fountains and we see lancer
turn to stone in front of our eyes
because this fact is true yet rosie a
member of the original dark fountain not
only crossed over into this new dark
world but exists here just fine
indefinitely but i'm saying all this to
prove that the dark world is both
influenced majorly by the light world
but is a completely real place at the
same time now let's bring this back to
asriel obviously there's some kind of
extremely strong connection between
asriel and rosie i mean they look
exactly the same well mostly the same
and rosie is intricately familiar with
chris and susie and the light world in
general and their names are anagrams of
each other so this means that azrael
didn't actually go off to college and
that he's actually been here the whole
time trapped inside the dark world as
rosie right
well uh maybe i mean i i guess that is a
possible theory but that's not where i
was going with this one at one point i
did believe that rosie was none other
than asriel for the aforementioned
obvious reasons but now i no longer
consider that to be the case and it's
all because of the queen's castle
specifically the holding rooms inside of
the castle specifically the last room
asriel's room all of a sudden for the
first time in either chapter of the
sequel to undertale azrael and ralsi are
both independently referenced inside the
dark world proving to us that these two
characters are in fact different from
one another otherwise it would just have
been called rosie's room or rosie's name
would just have been asriel in the first
place toby fox has proven to be very
particular over and over again with the
way that he reveals story details to the
playerbase so you know that this was
deliberate to make things even weirder
when chris tries to peek inside asriel's
room as they are able to do with all the
other rooms before chris doesn't see
anything inside but it's not because
they can't it's because they won't in an
extremely strange and telling detail
chris closes their eyes when peeking
into the room this unwillingness to see
on the other side of a doorway fits with
several other places in chapter 2 along
your journey throughout the cyber world
sometimes the party will come across
door frames that are seemingly empty
where there's no door in the frame but
yet the other side is just black or
[Music]
blank so this begs the question what is
on the other side of these doors or
specifically the other side of asriel's
door that chris refuses to see and does
this mean that they're connected as far
as i can tell though asriel's real
bedroom which is also chris's bedroom is
completely visible in toriel's house
leaving very little to the imagination
just a bunch of trophies and a computer
and some secrets hiding under the bed
you know normal teenage guy stuff what
could possibly be inside the room that
chris so blatantly does not want to see
that's not there in his real room i'll
get to that later on in the video but i
have a bunch of stuff to set up for so
that it'll make sense see toby and team
placed that door here in chapter 2
wanting players to see it and read that
asriel has officially and for the first
time not only been referenced in the
dark world but is a different person
than rosie altogether the puzzle that i
think we need to tackle first isn't the
contents of asriel's dark world room
just yet but rather rawlsy like i
mentioned earlier pretty much everything
about ralsi is weird his permanent
existence within the dark world without
having a lightworld counterpart his
detailed knowledge of chris and susie
and the schoolhouse layout in the light
world and his ability to exist away from
his own dark fountain or without it
entirely and the mystery of rawlsy is
pretty much non-solvable until you see
what happens at the end of chapter 2
when it reveals to us that the roaring
knight the blade wielding dark fountain
opener is probably none other than chris
themselves or i guess chris's body maybe
the part of chris that doesn't include
you the player the soul all of a sudden
rosie's existence begins to make a
little bit of sense see chris creates
dark fountains where they were not
previously located they create dark
worlds that were not previously existing
according to queen this is something
that all lighteners are apparently able
to do yet chris's body is the only one
that knew that fact previously or is
shown doing it at all so presently we
can assume that chris is the knight and
has always been the knight since chris's
body has been going off doing shady
stuff on its own for quite some time now
long enough to have gained reputation
with the dogs in undyne's jailhouse if
you think about it being able to create
entire other dark worlds means that you
can also create dark world inhabitants
right i'm sure you can probably tell
where i'm going with this by now because
rawlsy's weirdness seems to revolve
around chris what if that means that
chris created rousey specifically chris
without the soul without you now okay
forewarning things are about to get
really weird and speculative and i'm
about to mix in some undertale stuff so
if you haven't already buckle your
seatbelts if chris created rosie that
would answer lots of questions about
ralsi's weirdness going on since his
existence outside of his own dark world
can just be attributed to chris's
presence or his appearance and knowledge
of chris's schoolhouse and friends would
have come from chris's own mind not to
mention the seemingly intimate concern
rosie has for chris and the somewhat
intimate moments that the two share on
the swan boat ride are both a bit too
familiar for friends that have only
known each other for two days right so
if rosie was born from chris's own mind
the question is why i'm so glad you
asked here's where things are about to
get really crazy see we know that chris
was pretty close to their brother asriel
in fact they were really close and
asriel's gone off to college leaving his
little sibling chris behind this has no
doubt made chris feel really lonely as
any little sibling would be speaking
from experience there but it goes
further than that have you ever noticed
that there are no humans in deltarune
contrasting with the world of undertale
where monsters lived in their villages
in darkness under the surface in
delterun there are only monsters living
on top of the surface in the light of
the sun except for chris even chris's
immediate family is composed of all
monsters and not humans now i'm getting
somewhere with this and it'll all make
sense so hold on to get some more
information on the subject let's refer
back to the world of undertale for some
parallels in undertale toriel and asgore
have two children together asriel their
biological child and another adopted
human this human child is not frisk the
player this human child has existed long
before the events of the game that you
play through and their name is chara
i hear you rolling your eyes before you
get too turned off at introducing chara
into the mix just watch till the end
this will make sense i promise you as
many fans have pointed out since day one
chris from deltarune shares many blatant
similarities to chara although appearing
to be a slightly older version of the
original character while the color black
is used to outline objects in deltarune
chris's sprite's dark tones are colored
in with a dark brown instead of black
similarly to chara the single stripe
green and yellow sweater shirt that
chris wears is also of a similar style
and color to chara's single striped
green and yellow sweater shirt and their
hair is worn very similarly as well not
to mention the creepy smile that chris
flashes sometimes or the iconic knife
that they wield sometimes like chara was
known for but there's no way this is
charra right i mean from toby's own
words on the deltarune website deltarune
is not the world of undertale right i
mean he says that deliberately well
let's read into what he says a bit more
see it was always so strange to me that
toby would say so much to say so little
if it was as simple as no it's a
different universe then why not just say
that instead he kind of dances around
and confirms that there are connections
between the two worlds and says
specifically that if people were happy
in undertale they'd still be happy there
now he also emphasizes that specifically
undertale's ending has been left
untouched and that deltarune is meant
for people who have completed undertale
as a spiritual sequel to the former let
me ask you a really serious question do
you remember what happens at the end of
undertale's genocide route do you
remember that you the player frisk gave
chara your soul to reset the universe
now how char was able to reset the
universe isn't really important here i
mean maybe they partnered up with gaster
who's shown to be speaking at the
beginning of the new universe of
deltarune but that's another theory
entirely so let me know if you'd like
for me to go into my thoughts on that
particular subject in another follow-up
video to this one anyway it is a fact
that chara has reset the world and has
received your soul the player soul at
the end of the genocide route one might
say that the world was reset and is
immediately replayable by opening the
game again which is a closed case which
does happen but do we honestly think for
one second that chara as evil as they
are cares so much about you the player
that they would reset the world of
undertale only back to when frisk fell
down in the underworld no i think that
maybe frisk falling into the underworld
is somewhat of an inevitable future or
maybe just a closed time loop but i
think that chara ultimately resets the
world back to when chara was happy with
it when chara lived with asriel and
their parents and chara asked for your
soul because it was necessary for them
to come back to life and live once again
in the past with their family and once
this happened their name was changed
from chara to chris which is almost
frisk but not quite but since char was
reborn as chris in their original time
with all the knowledge of what happened
the first time around what if chris was
able to avoid becoming terminally ill as
chara and instead is able to do what
they wanted to do in the first place
with the power of frisk's soul and after
chris destroyed the humans they moved
their family and the other monsters to
charra's original village with the
golden flowers and trees instead of
remaining underground and sealed the
doorway shut explaining the mysterious
door to the south of the village and
which is why chris is apparently the
only one who knows what's behind the
door and asks all the other monsters to
keep out this reset world theory with
the other humans destroyed and monsters
moved to the surface also fits in with
toby's words on the deltarune website
since the good ending of undertale the
pacifist route would indeed remain
untouched as chara would never have
received the player's soul additionally
it makes sense that it would be the same
soul as the player soul in undertale
since after all toby said deltarine was
designed for people who have played
undertale right theoretically speaking
the vast majority of deltarune players
will have played undertale previously
meaning that either way the player's
soul in deltarune is probably the same
soul as your player's soul from
undertale because you are the link
between the two it also explains several
other things such as why the menu looks
the exact same as it does from undertale
in the light world or why chris would be
physically older than chara in deltarune
if chara got their way and killed the
humans and saved their beloved older
brother and now gets to live on with
their monster family why wouldn't they
be okay with living on and growing up
and they were until asriel left i think
that this is the key for this entire
theory when asriel left chris behind
chris's body chara couldn't take it they
needed asriel their only emotional link
to this world so they did something
about it they removed you frisk the
player's soul from their body once again
becoming chara and wielding their iconic
knife but because they need a soul to
live they slump around heavily like a
zombie and can't last too long without
reclaiming their player soul which is
what they needed to live again in the
first place however chara is able to
function freely long enough to create
dark worlds which are literal rpg worlds
full of imagination just like the dnd
games chris and their brother used to
play which is what they missed so much
and then created a clone of their
brother to play with asriel reborn as
rosie in the image of when they first
met asriel as a younger monster when
chara first fell down to the underworld
only chara named ralsi rawlsy instead of
asriel because their brother's real name
would remind them of the reality which
is that asriel is gone moving on with
his life never to return home for good
meaning things will never be the same as
they used to when they were kids and
finally what if rousey who is a creation
of chris i mean chara's own mind knows
the truth and knows that he himself is a
clone of the real azrael he still cares
about chris since he's a duplicate of
asriel and therefore loves his little
sibling but he wants chris to know the
truth that's why rosie seems so happy to
see chris but also oddly so sad at the
same time that's why he discourages
birdley from extending this world of
lies his own world and creating more
dark fountains at the end of chapter 2.
and since we know rosie can change
things around and literally create rooms
in the dark world without chris's
knowledge and unnaturally and
supernaturally quickly what if ralzy has
some sort of creation power in the dark
world and he's the one who's placed the
strange blank doorways around the dark
world and perhaps even created his
counterpart asriel's room in the queen's
palace where notice he was deliberately
not taken prisoner but allowed to roam
the castle freely this would explain why
he keeps finding ways to separate
himself from chris in order to create
these rooms which always seem to
randomly pop up right in the way of
where you're supposed to go meaning
you're supposed to find them the final
question is why would rousey create the
rooms and what's on the other side of
the doors well what if what's on the
other side of asriel's room and on the
other side of these other doors isn't
something physical but rather is the
truth the truth about rousey the dark
worlds and asriel as the player you may
want to see inside these rooms but chara
closes chris's eyes every time making
you see blank unwilling to uncover the
truth about the brother they cherish so
dearly that's why chara keeps ripping
you out of their body and opening new
dark fountains when rosie clearly wants
them to stop it's all because of the
first fallen human the little child
named chara the one who only cares about
what they want who loves their brother
so much that they are unwilling to let
them go of course this is all just my
theory though what did you guys think
there was a lot to unpack in this one
but do you think any of it carries water
is chris really chara reborn with the
player soul that was given to them at
the end of undertale and did rosie
create asriel's door of truth to force
chris to see the truth or is this all
just another undertale deltarune theory
fever dream let me know in the comments
below also huge thanks for watching this
was my first time covering undertale or
deltarune on the channel but as a huge
fan of the series i'd love to continue
onward let me know if you enjoyed it and
if you'd like to see more from me on
this series also please leave a like
below if you liked the video and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more geeky stuff to come huge kudos
as always to my bandit crew and i have
an apology to make actually dear
clifford longhead i apologize so much
for missing your announcement in the
last one i have no idea what happened
but i wanted to make a special welcome
for you in this video thanks so much for
joining up and if anyone else is
interested please feel free to click on
that join button located below that's
about all i've got in this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is maskington abandoned
looking forward to seeing you again and
signing out
[Music]
you